[Musica]
io non so diciamo che non so stare bene
sul palco davanti a un pubblico perché
io sto in uno studiolo a casa mia a
pontedera in provincia di pisa e lavoro
lì io lavoro da casa sono uno di quelli
di quei lavoratori che report in un
famoso servizio chiamerebbe quelli che
stanno in un loculo per 6 7 ore immobili
stregando il pubblico dei ragazzini ecco
diciamo che tutto un po diverso io
faccio lo streamer lo screamer non è
altro che una persona che trasmette in
diretta dei contenuti parla con il
proprio pubblico guarda dei video
insieme a loro e soprattutto interagisce
insieme a loro ci sono molte molte
chiacchiere si parla magari degli
argomenti di attualità del giorno si
parla degli argomenti caldi che girano
sull'internet insomma si fa salotto ma
salotto ovviamente non a livello formale
ma informale diciamo che siamo tutti
sullo stesso livello e ho iniziato a
farlo qualche anno fa e 23 anni fa l'ho
fatto per gioco perché io vengo da
youtube
facevo video su youtube dove parlavo di
cartoni animati e fumetti e il canale
youtube e mi andava abbastanza bene
a un certo punto non ho più
non c'è più campato non riuscivo a
vivere con quello che mi piaceva di più
perché io voglio fare quello volevo
creare dei video né parlare a un folto
pubblico delle mie passioni perché ci
credevo credevo che si potesse fare
purtroppo però youtube è cambiato io
sono cambiato perché sono cresciuto e
è arrivata sono arrivate le
responsabilità la casa la famiglia la
mia ragazza la mia compagna attuale e
quindi io dovevo iniziare a pagare le
bollette a pagarmi un mutuo un affitto
che sia e quindi ho provato contri ci ho
provato a interagire con il mio pubblico
in maniera diversa anche perché la cosa
che mi piaceva più di youtube penso che
tutti lo sapranno sono i commenti cioè
tutti voi potete commentare interagire
anche se la maggior parte le volte
finisce tutto a schifio e tutti i suoi
una grande a coltellate nel petto ecco a
me quella cosa piaceva e non piace va
infatti un moderato molto i miei
commenti su per youtube ecco twitch
appunto con la possibilità di commentare
in diretta ha portato questa forma di
interazione tra pubblico e esprimere
talent su un nuovo livello
anzi secondo me ha annullato lo spazio
che c'era tra il pubblico e il talent
quello che non mi piaceva mai della
televisione è il fatto che quando che
vedi un gerry scotti un amadeus un
bonolis presentare uno spettacolo un
programma in tv c'è sempre quello diceva
anche pasolini c'è sempre quella forma
un po di intimidatoria no lui comunque è
quello che ce l'ha fatta lui comunque il
vip
io sono quello che consuma il prodotto
che mi propone il vip non è per tutti
così però si sente sempre un po quel
quel timore riverenziale infatti molte
persone quando vedono un bonolis in giro
subito foto self i volti prego fammi un
autografo eccetera
a me questa cosa non è mai piaciuto
perché mi è sempre piaciuto il pubblico
e sono drogato di persone mi piace molto
interagire con loro fare vacanze con
loro è un po come all'hub il mare
infilarmi nel loro compleanni o nelle
loro feste io per esempio ho fatto una
storia dopo andrò a farmi in spiaggia
con il pubblico che vuole venire qui di
pugliese insomma sono uno che proprio
vuole annullare lo spazio che c'è tra il
talent e il pubblico è probabilmente un
modello john lennon
prima o poi qualcuno verrà amy sparerà
non lo so sono pronto anche a questo
però è la mia droga quindi fa anche in
un certo senso male e quando ho scoperto
questa interazione diretta c'è il
pubblico che commenta continuamente ogni
cosa che fai ogni cosa che dice mi ha
sempre colpito tantissimo perchè te hai
veramente un'interazione totale e
soprattutto io stiamo tutti i giorni e
comunque
ma radiofonico io dalle 21 e 45 alle 2
di notte
parlo parlo gioco interagisco con il mio
pubblico tutti i giorni a parte il
sabato con un programma un palinsesto a
volte guardo dei film a volte si parla
di del più e del meno a volte intervisto
persone sono venute persone del mondo
dello spettacolo del mondo della musica
del mondo del fumetto o intervistate
chiacchieriamo è molto bello è venuto
landini siamo divertiti un sacco è
avvenuto igort che è uno dei pesi
massimi del fumetto italiano ed è molto
bello perché si respira sempre
quell'area di naturalezza di di casa
perché io ho stream con un termosifone
dietro una tenda dietro e gatto che mi
scorre tra piedi e la mia ragazza che
batte sulla tastiera e rompe le palle a
tutti quelli che stanno ascoltando la
stream è però è così
è quello il bello tutto ha funzionato e
qui mi collego a quello che voglio dirvi
ha funzionato perché non c'è più non c'è
più niente non c'è più quella barriera
tra tale ente pubblico e questo è molto
prezioso perché per una vita siamo
abituati ci siamo stati abituati a
pensare diversamente
e infatti con il covip cosa è successo
twitch è esploso la piattaforma di
streaming live twitch è diventata una
delle maggiori piattaforme che il
pubblico dei più giovani
utilizzava per intrattenersi nei momenti
di solitudine è stato detto anche in
altri speech che aumentata la
depressione tra i giovani questo è vero
e lo percepisco avendo in un'interazione
bella diretta col mio pubblico ho
parlato anche con diciottenni
diciannovenni ventenni che non sanno
cosa fare sono incerti sul proprio
futuro non riescono a dialogare con la
propria famiglia non riescono a trovare
un amore non riescono a capire l'altro
sesso o la propria sessualità e questo è
molto importante perché con trichet sono
riusciti a trovare una compagnia a
trovare un amico che c'è sempre alle 21
e 45 c'è sempre pronto ad ascoltarli tra
interagirvi e altri tragici e
soprattutto a fare delle battute che
sicuramente li intratterranno e questa
cosa e lo la nottata soprattutto con una
delle cose di cui sono più orgoglioso e
non mi piace vantarmi di quello che
faccio però di questo sì io durante il
primo
da un fatto una live di beneficenza non
so se lo sapete
e questo crea anche molto molto schifo
diciamo ne l'uomo della strada sulpice
si possono donare dei soldi si possono
donare dei soldi allo streamer c'è un
tasto lo clicchi che si collega a paypal
tempo e donare 1 euro 2 euro addirittura
ci sono persone che donano 100 200 e
1000 euro allo streamer questa cosa fa
subito rabbrividire tutti perché è
comunque soldi che ti regali una persona
dell'internet a uno sconosciuto
bene io ho deciso di prendere questa
cosa di farlo diventare una forma di
beneficenza e abbiamo fatto una campagna
per raccogliere dei soldi per poi donare
all'ospedale di brescia e bergamo dei
respiratori
quando c'era moria di respiratori e così
abbiamo fatto abbiamo raccolto quasi 30
mila euro
siamo riusciti a raccogliere 30 mila
euro che io ho donato
poi ci sono le tasse di paypal che ci ho
messo di tasca mia siamo riusciti a
regalare questi respiratori e gli
ospedali sono ringraziato per questa
donazione un ospedale non mi ricordo poi
perché ovviamente nel casino non
potevano pensare a tutti i soldi che gli
arrivavano perché sono arrivate per
fortuna anche donazioni fuori da attrice
però è così
questo molto è molto importante prima
sentivo si parlava di di empatia
ecco quello che voglio dirvi è che
twitch non è necessariamente male
ultimamente sono uscite delle polemiche
su trici perché ci sono effettivamente
dei lati del coni d'ombra su questa
piattaforma
ci sono persone che fanno dei contenuti
un po strani dei contenuti a volte non
controllati dei contenuti borderline che
ovviamente possono effettivamente andare
a sconvolgere un po la mentalità
soprattutto dei più piccoli quindi io
sono qui più che altro per dirvi una
cosa c'è una marea di ragazzi
diciottenni di ventenni che hanno
bisogno di interfacciarsi con qualcuno
ma stessi interfacciano con una persona
che li intrattiene e non c'è niente di
male anche noi ci siamo intrattenuti con
i personaggi che vi citavo prima ci sono
persone che mentre vanno al lavoro si
ascoltano programmi radiofonici anche
bestiali come la zanzara dove si dice
ogni tipo di atrocità però
intrattenimento
l'unica cosa che mi raccomando e
teneteli d'occhio perché
si inizia a brontolare e si inizia a
indignarci solamente quando vengono
fuori le polemiche è molto importante
soprattutto in questo periodo
controllare i vostri ragazzi non sta lì
col fucile pronti ad aprire la stanza
mentre mentre guardano allo screamer no
però dovete interessarvi sinceramente di
quello che vedono e con chi si
interfacciano che a questo talent perché
lo ascolti quattro ore al giorno perché
ti interessa quello che ha da dire chi è
questa persona a chi stai dando i soldi
soprattutto perché ci sono dei 19 anni
venti anni che si trovano il primo
lavoretto oppure ricevono una paghetta
che le spendono anche per queste cose
qua perché perché effettivamente gli
abbiamo fatto compagnia
gli abbiamo fatto compagnia noi siamo
riusciti a farci compagnia perché io
dico la verità il periodo il comit anche
per me non è stato facile agosto faccio
31 anni ma non mi sarei mai aspettato di
stare chiuso in casa per così tanto
tempo e le live di tweet il mio lavoro
mi ha aiutato tantissimo a stare
tranquillo a rilassarmi a divertirmi e
anche quest'ultimo anno dove ho ricevuto
una brutta notizia
il mio pubblico c'era c'era sempre e
questa cosa mi spinge tutti i giorni
andare in live alle 21 e 45 incontrarli
e parlarci e continuare con questa
filosofia qua e ovvero quella di
incontrarli sempre e di abbracciarli
quando hanno bisogno di un sostegno
perché so che loro ci saranno ovviamente
i miei sono un po folli accusano un tipo
di ironia strana sono fanno dei commenti
molto entranti sono anche un po a
cinelli però dentro di loro si nasconda
appunto un animo buono ed è quello su
cui bisogna lavorare per cercare di
capire questa generazione che
effettivamente ha qualcosa da dire e
anche su internet
e quando sono su internet non è che
stanno seguendo dei degenerati
semplicemente si stanno intrattenendo
con le nuove forme di intrattenimento
che stanno venendo fuori in questi
ultimi anni quindi cercate di capirle e
non rigettarle a priori perché anche su
cui ci sono persone piene di talento e
sono persone che parlano di scienza sono
persone che parlano di biologia ci sono
grandi intrattenitori grandi comici ci
sono persone che veramente
arricchiscono le persone quando parlano
di qualcosa e poi c'è una famiglia tipo
la mia che è pronta veramente
intrattenere in ogni momento la loro
vita
quindi questa è la mia raccomandazione
siate empatici con le nuove generazioni
soprattutto siate empatici con le nuove
forme di intrattenimento perché loro non
vi rigettano al fatto grazie mille
[Applauso]